Радянські пам'ятники. Залишити чи знести?
Як слід учинити з пам’ятниками комуністичного режиму? Що це: пам'ять про загиблих солдатів або ж символи, які активно використовує російська пропаганда?
Через майже 35 років після падіння комунізму у Східній Європі знову спалахнула дискусія.
Болгарія – особливий випадок.
Це монумент радянській армії в центрі Софії.
Яке б не було рішення щодо пам’ятника Радянській Армії, воно безнадійно спізніле.
Це пам’ятник, це не просто каміння, це пантеон. У жодному разі не можна його знищувати.
Ми довели, що це не пам’ятка культури, також ми довели через певні інституції,
що це не є пам’ятником загиблим воїнам.
Можливий вихід – перетворити пам’ятник на музей. Це змусить усі сторони піти на поступки та заповнить
порожнечу, яка виникла через відсутність такого музею та відсутність загальної інформації про часи терору.
Після падіння комунізму бюсти Леніна та комуністичних діячів вивезли з багатьох міст.
Деякі опинилися на складах, інші - в музеях.
Більшість велетенських пам'ятників і досі стоїть.
Ситуація змінилася після початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії на територію України в лютому 2022 року.
Пам'ятники почали терміново демонтувати. Як-то в Ризі.
У Болгарії поки що нічого не знесли. Тут нема єдиної думки щодо долі радянських військових монументів.
Софія, 9 травня 2023 року.
День, який ділить суспільство на два табори.
У Софії майорять радянські, російські, європейські та болгарські прапори.
Одні відзначають День перемоги над нацистською Німеччиною,
інші - День Європи.
Суперечки навколо пам'ятника Радянській армії багато років розколювали болгарське суспільство.
Тут є й ті, хто радикально відмовляється від приналежності до Заходу,
і ті, котрі виступають за особливий національний шлях Болгарії.
Є і проєвропейські активісти.
Зрозуміло одне: опрацюванням минулого тут ніхто не займався.
У Болгарії комуністичні часи радше романтизують, на відміну від інших країн Східного блоку, таких як Польща.
Багато років тут узагалі не говорили про жахи та злочини комуністичного режиму.
Це залишило багато простору для проблемних інтерпретацій.
Заповнити історичну прогалину та знести пам'ятник – мета цих жителів Софії.
Ми вже 10 років проводимо тут акції протесту та виступаємо за те, щоб монумент демонтували.
Нам хотілося б, щоб цю площу припинили політизувати, бо цей пам'ятник розколює нас як суспільство.
Через пам'ятник ми не можемо використовувати це місце. Він не дивиться в майбутнє,
а обслуговує злочинну пропаганду минулого та є причиною напруги в суспільстві.
Ще 1993 року міська рада ухвалила прибрати пам'ятник.
Але з того часу жодна структура та жодна людина не наважилися взяти відповідальність на себе і знести пам'ятник.
Юридично пам'ятник не є ані культурним надбанням, ані монументом
пам'яті загиблих воїнів. Це з'ясували активісти.
Після приходу Червоної армії в Болгарії встановили комуністичний режим.
Ця пам'ятка була створена в той час, коли окупанти називали себе визволителями в невільній державі.
Сьогодні ми спостерігаємо щось подібне в Україні: армія просто вдирається на територію чужої
країни та оголошує себе визволителькою, якщо виграє війну.
Те саме сталося свого часу в Болгарії.
Наприкінці Другої світової війни Радянський Союз був однією з держав, які перемогли нацистську Німеччину.
Під час "холодної війни" альянс переможців розпався, і Болгарія стала частиною комуністичного
Східного блоку, в якому домінував Радянський Союз.
Болгарія - унікальний випадок в історії Східної Європи після Другої світової війни.
Болгарія була союзницею нацистської Німеччини, але підтримувала мир
та активні дипломатичні відносини з Радянським Союзом
протягом усієї Другої світової війни.
По-друге, Болгарія була окупована Червоною армією в вересні 1944 року без будь-якого опору.
Для окупації не було жодної причини і жодного приводу.
Знищення болгарської політичної та культурної еліти було наймасштабнішим
у порівнянні з іншими європейськими країнами.
Водночас Болгарія - єдина країна Східної Європи, яка так і не змогла показати послідовну та чітку
позицію щодо оцінки режиму, окупації та спадщини комунізму.
Білі плями в історії країни заповнюють іншими яскравими кольорами.
Гурт художників у 2011 році розмалював радянську армію. Червоноармійців перетворили на "суперменів".
Відтоді пам'ятник надихнув багатьох на подібні акції.
У 2013 році монумент засяяв рожевим кольором - на знак вибачення за участь Болгарії у придушенні Празької весни.
У 2014 році його розфарбували синьо-жовтим - на знак солідарності з Україною та проти Росії,
яка незаконно анексувала Крим.
Акції, які тут проводять, - це добре. Це доказ того, що ми принаймні вільно виявляємо себе за допомогою мистецтва
на вулиці. Якщо акція зачіпає живе, то ЗМІ її висвітлюють.
Щодо цього немає медійної заборони, немає цензури, принаймні так ми своїми діями сприяємо діалогу.
Інша річ, як вести цей діалог.
Чи притягують за такі акції до суду, часто залежить від мінливих настроїв політичної влади.
Тому група художників залишається анонімною.
Наша пропозиція зробити монумент частиною Музею терору змусить обидві сторони піти на поступки.
Більше того, музей заповнить порожнечу, а саме - відсутність інформації про терор і той період
нашої історії загалом.
Адже якщо ми знищуватимемо пам'ятники, то чинитимемо так, як колись чинили комуністи.
Вони теж знищували пам'ятники.
Є й інші варіанти:
інтегрувати монумент у місцевий музей або перевезти його в інше місто. У Софії є підхоже місце.
Музей соціалістичного мистецтва.
Тут є Ленін в усіх позах, Че Гевара та лідер болгарських комуністів Георгій Димитров.
У ті часи мистецтво було засобом пропаганди. Воно стало інструментом політичної влади та ідеології.
Комуністична партія злилася з державою. Однопартійна держава контролювала всі сфери життя:
суспільну, політичну, культурну та інші.
Мистецтво було частиною цих процесів.
Ніколай Уштавалійський - директор музею з 2011 року. Він зацікавлено стежить за дискусією про радянський
пам'ятник у Софії. Чи місце йому тут – у парку завбільшки з футбольне поле? Директор музею має іншу пропозицію.
Є ідея демонтувати пам'ятник та перевезти його до міста Димитровград.
Це десь 200-250 кілометрів від Софії. Цікаво, що це місто заснували в перші роки соціалізму.
Його побудували майже з нічого. Димитровград став символом будівництва нового соціалістичного суспільства
в Болгарії. Перенести пам'ятник у це місто - зовсім не екзотична ідея,
адже сам Димитровград — пам'ятник соціалізму.
Там місце такому пам'ятнику, як той, що стоїть у Софії та вшановує іноземну армію.
Ті, хто святкує День Перемоги 9 травня, дотримуються іншої точки зору.
Ці люди прийшли сюди з фотографіями родичів, які загинули під час Другої світової війни,
та з російськими прапорами. Вони вважають, що пам'ятник має залишитися на своєму місці як символ боротьби з фашизмом.
Це наш спільний пам'ятник, який має нагадувати про те, що на тій війні – огидній, кривавій та лютій – загинуло стільки
людей, які ніколи не хотіли тієї війни.
Пам'ять про неї має бути збережена. Ця війна триває досі - війна між Заходом, тобто США, та Росією.
Росія завжди була скалкою в оці для тих, хто хоче використовувати величезні ресурси і територію Росії для власного збагачення.
Чимало болгар вірять путінській пропаганді під час теперішньої війни Росії проти України.
Болгарія ніколи не виходила з-під російського впливу.
Майже через 35 років після падіння комуністичного режиму перед Болгарією стоїть важливе завдання: послідовна переоцінка історії.
Агресивна війна Росії проти України призвела до нової хвилі суперечок про минуле.
Болгарія виборює свою ідентичність.
Перед країною-членом ЄС та НАТО постає велике завдання.